good morning believe nation today's
message is focus over to you Kevin Plank
focus you know we talked about today was
just in my office I've run my company
much like a team in sales and marketing
like offense and manufacturing
distributions like defense and Finance
and IT or like the special teams but
when you find out is that all those
pieces the companies that win are the
ones that communicate the best and it's
not one teams on the field at a time
we're all in the field at the same time
and so I think the ability to never one
to communicate and number two to focus
you know too often you know I get pulled
all the time of you know what you guys
should make is you should make one of
these or make one of those and why don't
you do anything for pets and how could
you go there you know great brands or
like great stories and every great story
has a beginning a middle and an end
and our jobs to make sure that every
chapter of our stories make sense the
one in front of it makes sense the one
after it as entrepreneurs it's hard to
stay focused sometimes it's hard to stay
on the path especially not seeing
immediate results and it's easy to get
distracted you see other people make a
lot of money in different fields and
somebody throws you an opportunity and
you feel like man I can make a lot of
cash here so I'm gonna try it out and it
almost never works out and then you feel
like a total failure and that's a super
common trend in entrepreneurship you
know part of belief for me is believing
in yourself is to self-confidence but
also believing in what you're doing and
then believing that it's gonna work out
and in order to do that you have to stay
focused you have to stay on your path
you have to believe that what you're
doing is important that it's going to
help people and that it's going to work
out and if you can stay on that path
you're much more likely to be successful
as an entrepreneur instead of jumping
around from thing to thing to thing and
you're much more likely to have a big
impact and be a happier person as well
so my question of the day for you today
is how do you stay focused or better yet
what are the distractions that come up
in your life in your business what keeps
you from being focused you get the pick
either what how you stay focus or what
keeps you from being focused leave it
below I'm really curious to find out
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso